but I would say at the earliest stage
right like
you guys made this view in a day I made
this analogy we're like a lot of people
need to be awoken to really realize
their potential and not just go watch
Netflix or go about their day and you
know waste time and traffic commuting
and all this stuff right and so but you
made the point that people don't people
can be like the grizzly bear when they
do wake up but they don't wake up
fighting right they wake up and slowly
come out of hibernation and like they're
tired and the groggy and then slowly
over time over actually months to like a
year people change and become almost
this new person they reprogrammed
themselves to be an entrepreneur right
but I would say during that process you
don't know what you don't know right and
you don't which means you think you
should maybe be paying attention to some
things but in reality your mentors never
that's already gone through this journey
it's telling you need to be fo you
paying attention over here right and I
would say